Narrator: It's like they
have magical powers.
When the weather warms,
fruit flies just appear.
Out of nowhere.
Next to the fruit bowl,
near the trash, everywhere.
And once they arrive, they
are determined to stay
no matter how many you
swat, squash, or seize.
Now as far as we know,
fruit flies can't teleport
into our homes from
another grosser dimension.
So where do they come from,
and why are they so hard
to get rid of?
Meet Drosophila melanogaster:
your standard fruit fly.
It can smell a meal from
more than a kilometer away
all thanks to the tiny
antennae on top of its head.
These antennae are specially attuned to
sniff out chemicals like acetic acid
let off by rotting fruit,
and once they're locked on to the scent,
it's nearly impossible to
keep them out of your home.
That's because fruit flies are about
the size of a sesame seed,
so they can slip through almost any crack,
screen, or gap.
But contrary to popular belief,
it's not just the smelly
fruit they're after.
They're also hunting for the
source of that rotting stench,
specifically, fungi and
other microorganisms.
Yum!
And once they land for the
feast, things turn even nastier.
You know how you never
see just one fruit fly?
That's because they have
incredibly fast life cycles.
A single female fruit fly can
lay up to 100 eggs a day, which
hatch in less than 24 hours.
The maggots then tunnel
under the fruit skin,
feeding on the microbial rot.
In just a few days later, they pupate
into fully fledged fruit flies.
By the time day 11 or 12 rolls around,
they're ready to have
little maggots of their own.
Aww.
That's why your home can
go from fruit-fly free
to infested in under two weeks.
Now, by this point you might start
swatting them down one by one.
But it's not so easy, right?
Perhaps even...fruitless?
Well, scientists have discovered why.
Turns out fruit flies are
mathematical wizards of escape.
For starters, they have
around 270-degree vision,
so they can see you coming
from almost any angle:
front, back, or side to side,
and they will actually calculate the angle
of your attack and plan
their escape accordingly
all in as little as 100 milliseconds.
Scientists figured this out because
of how a resting fruit fly will reposition
its legs when it senses an attack.
If your hand's coming from
the front, for example,
fruit flies move their
middle legs forward,
lean back, and raise
their legs, allowing for
a fast backwards takeoff.
Once in midair, killing
them isn't much easier.
They can change directions within
one one-hundredth of a
second and quickly accelerate
by flapping their wings
200 times per second.
Not bad for a brain that's even smaller
than a house fly's.
So then, how do you get rid of them?
Some experts suggest making a trap.
Fill a container with 2
centimeters of cider vinegar,
cap it with a funnel, and
then tape around the perimeter
so that no flies can crawl out.
You see, fruit flies are
smart enough to find fruit
but not the hole they entered.
But here's the thing.
Even if you trap every last fly,
they will come back as long
as there's something to eat.
And unfortunately for you,
fruit flies aren't picky.
They love rotten fruit, sure,
but wine and other fermented liquids,
which are chock-full of
those microbes they adore,
are also tasty,
as is the slime that builds
up in your kitchen sink.
So really, the only thing you can do
to get rid of them is to,
well, clean up.